how David Goggins became that guy that
guy
you are a guy that for a lot of people
you sort of embody the idea
of hardening your mind and figuring out
a way to do things that most people
think are impossible
you've sort of become that guy
how did you become that guy you know
what I grew up not that guy
they see me now as the guy that with his
shirt off who can do four thousand
Thirty pull-ups in 17 hours you can run
205 miles in 39 hours we can do all this
crazy [ __ ] but what they don't
understand is they don't understand the
journey that it took me to get to this
point how the [ __ ] does he do that many
pull-ups
my dad beat the [ __ ] on me when I was
growing up my dad owned skating rinks he
owned bars he ran prostitutes from
Canada to Buffalo New York
my dad was a big time pimp Big Time
Hustler
anything bad about a person
he was that kind of guy
beat the [ __ ] out of me but this [ __ ]
out you know out of my mom there was an
incident one time and my mom got knocked
out on top of the stairs and he juggled
down the stairs by her hair in my mind I
was always afraid my whole life I was
afraid but I had this [ __ ] voice this
this conscience that would always be
battling me saying hey you got to get up
and do something I didn't want to do
[ __ ]
and I have a big time learning
disability because my dad didn't believe
in us going to school
so when I went to school my learning
disability I had social anxiety I was
just a jacked up kid from living in this
tortured home so all the insecurities I
have when I was a kid with my father it
just got worse and worse and worse and
it haunted me and that voice that I
talked about it kept talking louder and
louder and louder but I was doing
nothing about it that's great it's so
crazy to like look back at elementary
school and think of like what the other
kids went through and you just have no
idea it's wild stuff yeah I have a hard
time with that it makes me so sad to
think that as we're sitting here right
now there's a child being neglected or
abused yes or watching their mother take
a beating that's horrible I mean it's
just it's really sad I don't know what
foot it what film this footage is from
but that Joe wrote oh like the actor
playing his dad in this is a is a famous
actor so this must be a real movie that
they're putting footage from from the
age of 19 the age of 22. I gained 125
pounds
and I started finding things that was
comfortable
and the more things I found comfortable
the more uncomfortable my mind was
because that voice I was telling you
about it always was there
I was just trying to avoid that
conscience
I wanted to be left alone from that
conscience and it wouldn't leave me
alone
what changed I bought this Discovery
Channel show class 224 class 224.
yet that conscience he's talking about
though I I totally can understand that
because like there's some times where I
just like screw off and I just watch you
know play too much chess or I don't know
that's what I've been doing lately it's
just like I'll play a bunch of Chess or
something and then it just hits a point
where you're like I just I have to do
something productive like I can't just
like not do anything and so many people
just don't even acknowledge that they're
doing nothing they just do nothing they
go to work make like 10 bucks an hour
and then they just like play 2K or just
like watch TV and that's that's it it's
just like well it's my time off this is
this is what I do it's it's so crazy to
me how people don't self-analyze but
it's really like I mean maybe it's just
because I'm in the entrepreneurial space
and like I surround myself with these
kinds of people but I don't know it's
it's just it's crazy how many regular
people don't do that and they just go
about their lives just you know doing
nothing so it's funny that that's what
you heard and you're so right on
everything you just said but what I
heard was you know this the voice that
it's like that I just always felt like I
like there was something bigger and more
important for me to be doing and I could
never put my finger on it or achieve it
I think one of the things I went after
weren't weren't necessarily it and you
know now that I'm like becoming like a
Jesus lady I'm like oh maybe that just
wasn't God's plan and it just had to
unfold and I had to be able to like let
that unfold the way it's meant to but
that's what I'm hearing like you know
times in my life I can look back on and
my life's been a lot longer than yours
and say you know I wasn't living
anywhere near my potential and having
those moments like feeling like I know
there's more for me I know I can do
better than this but I didn't know what
to do so I just stayed and that's I
think what he's talking that's what I
heard and what he was talking about but
I think both of our translations make
perfect sense I was gonna say I think
all guys have that voice in them but
nowadays The Matrix is so deep that
there's like so many distractions to
where it can kill that voice like if
you're bored and something's hard like
starting a business you can just scroll
on Tick Tock and and kill that voice
because it just empties your brain so
there's so many different distractions
you can just scroll on Instagram
Snapchat Tick Tock Twitter it's like a
cycle back and forth every time you open
your phone and it's it's true but it's
meant to kill that voice even even if
the way I interpreted that what you just
said is true of that also no I know
because this can easily just distract me
from you know feeling like ah I know
there's more for me and and I should do
something about it and it's the same you
know I'll just I fight it all the time
sometimes if like I've been doing work
and then it gets a little hard and I
take a quick break and then it's like oh
my God it's been 30 minutes like where
did that time go it just scrolled on
like Family Guy Tick Tock videos with
soap cutting screens on the bottom and
I'm just like
it's like mind-numbing and the thing is
I think I was gonna say like I think a
lot of the people like with covid a lot
of the Real G's were able to you know
listen to that voice inside of them
because you had so much free time you
know what I mean like I know that's what
I did during covid yeah I mean I I
grinded fortnite at first but I was at
least trying to like be a pro player
like I wasn't just playing for nothing
like some people laid around watched
Netflix got fat and complained that
after kova they had to lose 50 pounds
and some people sat in their lips sat in
their living rooms and got ripped
started dropping didn't need to go to
the gym yeah didn't need to go to the
drawer the the gym they got ripped or
they started an online business yeah
okay no I'll just say it's fascinating
to me how people had that much free time
and they didn't like watch
entrepreneurial videos or try to learn
about money it's like I don't know even
like At first I I would I started
journaling and I was like all right an
hour a day of these videos and it's
crazy because that was like at one point
my goal for the day was to just watch
these videos or three videos of this
online course I bought for like an hour
a day and then the rest I could grind
for or whatever the [ __ ] and then slowly
it just becomes to like that's all
you're like your free time is doing what
that goal was it's funny
yeah you really gotta find it
with it you know I know I can do it I
know I can finish it I know I can do
anything they throw at me
uh that's where I build characters if
you find out if you got in yourself I'll
watch the show and it made me reflect
big time on the piece of [ __ ] that I am
and I'm exactly what people said I was
going to be I was watching these guys
going through hell week
hell week the most breaded week of bugs
it's the ultimate test of one's physical
and mental motivation a round-the-clock
regimen of intensive physical training
and harassment with as little as four
hours of sleep during the entire week
and these guys are ringing the bell
quitting dropping their helmet down
rolling out a lot of guys just leaving
and it made me reflect on my fears my
insecurities
and I saw real men when I thought were
real men who were staying who were
overcoming adversity who were overcoming
all these different things that I had
blamed so many [ __ ] people in my life
my dad my mom for not being there my
learned disability my my skin color
foreign
I sat there for a while and I was like
No One's Gonna [ __ ] come to help me
No One's Gonna [ __ ] come to help me
it's [ __ ] me against me period
[Music]
I had to man up and I said of course the
guy started doing his face in every
[ __ ] fear I have
stopped for a sec so that first thing I
have to start doing is facing every fear
I have if you really get started to
think about that that takes more than a
minute but what are you really afraid of
is there a conversation you've been
dreading is there you know something
bigger than that like whatever it is for
everybody I think it's worth it to like
stop and really really think about that
and then think about like I gotta deal
with that I gotta confront that I gotta
cross that bridge and walk into that
fire like what is it do you know I think
it's like a bunch of different things to
be honest oh it can be it can be a lot
of things it doesn't have to be one
thing no I know but like for me sticking
like what I struggle with is like waking
up in the morning and sticking to a
routine you know but he's talking about
like he reflected and said I gotta face
that the things I've been afraid of and
when we play again we'll find out what
he says what that he's afraid of but so
many people do that and imagine I guess
just like struggle like it seemed like
he was just like afraid with being
uncomfortable because he was asking
about him I'm asking about you oh you're
asking about me and it may not be on the
top of your head because like he said it
took reflection and it does take time
but I I'm going to think about that more
after this like what is it that I'm
afraid of all right let's see what it
was he was afraid of come on recruiters
up I said I'm gonna go be a [ __ ] Navy
SEAL
there's a weight and height limit to get
in the military
and I was six foot one and 297. and I
called this guy named Steven saljo
recruiter up and he said hey come on in
he saw me put me through the weight
standard all this sort of stuff and to
get into the class I had to get into how
to lose 106 pounds in less than three
months
so I was like [ __ ] that I can't do that
I grabbed my chocolate milkshake and
went back to Ecolab we spray for
cockroaches
I'm going back to work man this is my
life
damn
wow
all that cockroach is too much I hit the
motherload of cockroaches and I sat
there and said this is my life
this ain't gonna be it for me
so I quit my job got back in my Ecolab
truck and I went home
so my first run when I decided to lose
the weight I was like I said 297. I was
about 32 body fat my idea was to run
four miles for my first run I didn't
know how bad it's gonna [ __ ] hurt me
I used to run before I was fat and I was
like [ __ ] it I can do this I ran a
quarter mile and walked home
I walked home and sat on my couch and
cried
I said man I can't [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
I don't know what I'm gonna do
and my mind just kept [ __ ] with me
and kept [ __ ] you're not good enough man
this isn't for you man these guys the
best [ __ ] on the planet Earth
you're not that
how do you move forward what it was and
it's kind of funny I was obsessed with
Rocky and I would fast forward with the
little VHS tapes to round 14.
round 14 [ __ ] me up like nobody's
business
when Apollo Creed beat the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of Rocky beat the [ __ ] out of him he
kept fighting he was a dumb fighter
couldn't read couldn't write that was me
he was in the corner everybody was
saying stay the [ __ ] down down stay down
follow dancing around with his arms in
the air and him getting up
him getting up Apollo Creed raised his
arms up in the [ __ ] air turn around
thought he won the fight
he turns around and sees this guy
getting up and it was the face of Apollo
Creed that changed my life
the face of Apollo Creed it was like
just by that [ __ ] getting up
not winning just by him getting that's
going to be my first tattoo is don't let
them win what's your mother's favorite
movie of all time Rocky yeah I love this
the night before the fight so Rocky for
those of you if you haven't seen this
movie just turn this off and go watch
Rocky and then come back okay because it
is the best movie it won an Oscar for
best picture it is my favorite movie of
every movie ever but the night before
the fight and I'm not giving any
spoilers away you know Rocky he was just
like an average Joe like ham and egg or
loser boxer was never going to go
anywhere and he had this chance you know
to fight for the title and the night
before he was just walking around the
neighborhood he couldn't sleep any and
he went home to his girlfriend and the
conclusion he came to was he didn't
think he could win but he wanted to go
the distance because he just didn't want
to be another bum from the neighborhood
and like to me that is one of my
favorite parts of any movie seeing this
guy in the struggle the mental struggle
before and then seeing him get up after
he's gotten his ass kicked and like he
said when everyone was telling him to
stay down you got to see this movie it's
the [ __ ] best sure haven't seen it we
answered again this time
had literally taken his soul his his
head goes down he looks down like who
what the [ __ ] are you
look at it I want it to be that I want
to be the guy that people looked at I
don't care if you like me or didn't like
I don't care but said this [ __ ]
is gonna keep coming after whatever the
[ __ ] is in front of him I wanted that I
wanted that I wanted that worse than
anything in the world
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it sounds corny and it sounds weak but
it's true
what story would it be if my [ __ ] fat
dumb insecure ass
can overcome this [ __ ]
what if I can be a sealed man how would
that feel
to to to go from this fat insecure
[ __ ] to one of the best guys on
the planet Earth this journey is going
to take something that is going to be
incomprehensible to most people
so I would sit in my couch saying who at
297 who can't [ __ ] swim that great
who scare the [ __ ] water would have
to [ __ ] balls clear the balls to
[ __ ] man up quit a job and to put
everything on himself
so it's how I start talking to myself
and putting myself in a whole different
category and that would fuel me the next
day and I just kept using that as fuel
and fuel no one would do this [ __ ] no
one would do this [ __ ] you're the best
[ __ ] around you're the best
[ __ ] ever live
I just kept fueling me with the with the
right kind of message that I needed to
hear that I was never telling myself
from being defeated to like man all
right [ __ ] maybe you know maybe
Marvin go 0.75 but I started realizing I
can't run that far
so what I did was I became damn near a
professional cyclist with the miles I
put it on the bike I rode a bike a lot
to to lose the first initial kind of
weight because it took my bones were
just hurting so bad my body was just
broken
and then the bike got easier I was able
to run more I went from like one mile
one mile is a great accomplishment two
miles and then from two to three was a
big one then I went from three to six
they have a warning order that they give
people to get ready for Buds and the
whole thing was running six miles five
days a week and that was my goal
failed I go back to scratch I used some
positive motivation I had like one day
where I like [ __ ] defeated
but I started realizing this is part of
the process this is part of the journey
versus just saying like I used to I'm
just not good enough
we always say that [ __ ] I mean it's not
good enough and then we try something
else
I'm gonna [ __ ] make myself good
enough
and that became my mentality
I had to invent a guy that didn't exist
I had to invent a guy that can take any
pain any suffering any kind of judgment
I had to build this callous mind and I
built it through suffering
I built it through downright [ __ ]
just crushing myself if it was raining
outside three o'clock in the [ __ ]
morning if it was snowing my intake was
we gotta [ __ ] go out there you know
what the only thing is that that people
people will they'll bristle and they'll
say I can't do that oh that sucks I
don't want to do that I don't do that
it's just a different suffering you're
gonna suffer no matter what you're
either gonna suffer being a fat and lazy
eating Doritos on the couch watching
some dumb TV show and never achieving
any dream that is suffering yeah you're
right you know what this is also
suffering but the outcome and the
lifestyle that you get to live and the
health and the freaking mindset you know
the outcomes are totally different life
sucks either way yeah you gotta think
like what I think about too is like when
I'm older it's like the oh what if I
could have done this when I'm younger
and it's just like that time's just gone
like that's that's probably one of my
fears it's like when you're old and it's
just like I could have done so much more
like that sounds whole that sounds like
a horrible thought that I just like
don't want to experience yeah I know and
I have some some things like some things
around that that like I feel like you
know squandered youth but you know you
gotta let it go too and just be like all
right I still could have another 50 60
years here so I'm going to run you know
work on those but you're right that is
that then that should be a fear doesn't
mean you have to accomplish everything
that ever crosses your mind but it
should be a fear why not you want to be
on your deathbed and look back and go I
did all right you know I'm pleased with
my I'm pleased with the man I became but
again sucks either way might as well
suffer and get a good outcome I love
that
[ __ ] horrible in my life that I would
normally say no that was inhumane to
most people I had to go do it
and I lost the weight
I went back to recruiter I got into that
class
and I went through three Navy still held
weeks in one year
only God ever be in three hell weeks in
one year to my knowledge the first one I
didn't make it through the next two I
did
I'm 35 I don't know how long it took him
I didn't stop it saying from there and I
started realizing through this through
this process
that the [ __ ] mind is what you
created
and I started opening different doors
that I didn't think were even there that
anything even existed and the more doors
opened up the more I started realizing
that my potential is damn near endless
[Music]
if anybody knows my life story I'll try
to give you a just a snippet of it to
get through where I'm at now there's
nothing but Pride I have for myself that
I can't really I can't really show
people because I have this face I have
this faith that they see like are you
happy what's wrong with you
you're missing the story man
am I happy what the [ __ ] do you think
don't misunderstand the passion in which
I speak for not being intensely happy
but I'm not done no I have a lot more
[ __ ] to do
a lot more [ __ ] to do
yeah I don't know how some people like
just don't intake this content it's like
some people just don't watch any of this
stuff they don't watch him they don't
watch the tapes they don't watch any of
these dudes I'm like that's just crazy
to me it's like such life-changing stuff
to see but even if they do some people
are so damaged that they default back to
I could never do that how many times
you've had you're only 19 and you've had
those conversations with people I I
could never do that why not you why not
you this guy could still be killing
roaches he could beat 350 pounds by now
killing cockroaches for a living now and
no nothing wrong with that if you're you
know really truly content in your life
but like he wasn't he wasn't content and
he had that voice in him that said
there's more for me I don't know what it
is but there's you know what if he had
more distractions and [ __ ] like maybe he
had a girlfriend like when a fat girl
that he was content with chilling with
he had a phone that could keep him
distracted all day who knows like it
makes you just more susceptible to being
easily trapped it sounds sounds bad it
sounds horrible but I'm almost like I'm
not glad but it's like me recognizing
that there's a trap I'm like all right
well that's like 90 of the competition
gone all these people just like they're
all like addicted to like just consuming
content like you're never gonna surpass
what I'm trying to do if like everyone
you know what I mean that sounds like a
dick thing to say right you're well no
let me put it in a nicer way you're only
competing with a small percent of the
population whose drugs that's the thing
is like if you just like you don't even
have to like it feels like there's not
much competition in business
realistically you know what I mean there
is but but you're right when you really
think about it like you know it was a um
like I'm not doing crazy but it's Lonely
at the Top it's because there's not that
many people at the top and you know so
there's but there's also room
no I know there's room to get there and
so you shouldn't be afraid of the
competition no I'm saying I know people
do stuff better than me obviously like
I'm not making you know a million
dollars a month but you know what I'm
saying no I didn't hear I didn't hear
you like yeah it didn't sound like that
yeah no there's competition there are
people that are bad people just people
that are like trying to get better but
there's not so much competition that you
can't make it no it's like you literally
just like honestly just try and you you
make it like I don't know anyone that
hasn't just tried hasn't networked
hasn't started posting content for their
personal brand hasn't stunned constant
self-analyzation like there's no one I
know that's done that and not made it
all right thank you guys so much for
watching make sure to like subscribe
join my Discord it's free I have some
free social media tips and follow me on
Instagram I'm giving a hundred dollars
to someone who follows my Instagram
follow you're not you're not eligible
not eligible for any of the good stuff
home oh my God there's a big [ __ ]
crack in the first shot I'd rather
riding on the wall won't last long yeah
the feelings
[Music]